when america voted in 2020 there was one
issue both republicans and democrats
could agree on
an overwhelming majority of voters said
yes to the legalization of marijuana
montana voters gave their clear backing
to marijuana
arizona south dakota you could say a lot
of new jersey voters are high tonight
new jersey arrests around 30 000 people
a year for marijuana possession
more than almost any other state but
this year they voted to legalize
marijuana
arizona voted to legalize it too so did
montana
so did south dakota medical marijuana
was passed in mississippi now one in
three americans live in a state where
access to marijuana has been legalized
oregon took it even
further and decriminalized possession of
all drugs on election day
over decades america's war on drugs has
put millions of people in prison
and today it's widely understood to have
disproportionately affected people of
color
for example black americans use
marijuana at the same rates as white
americans
but are arrested for it at a much higher
rate
this map shows that more and more
americans are starting to turn
against the country's harsh drug laws
but ending them entirely will be a lot
more complicated
[Music]
americans used to be almost unanimously
against legalizing marijuana
today two out of three americans support
it
but politicians not so much there's a
lag between public embrace
of issues particularly cannabis policy
state legislators or even members of
congress
john hudak is a policy researcher who
writes about america's marijuana
policies
and he says the gap between how
politicians and the public feel about
marijuana
has a lot to do with what kind of
political issue it is
most americans don't use cannabis most
americans have never been
arrested for a cannabis related offense
etc and so it ends up not being
something
that they are going to hold elected
officials
accountable for americans usually choose
who they vote for because of issues like
the economy or health care
issues like marijuana are pretty far
down the list of priorities
but when you ask them directly hey do
you want marijuana legalized
they'll say yes and that's why almost
all of these states have legalized
marijuana in a very similar way
instead of the state legislature passing
a comprehensive
detailed law it was put directly to the
people on election day as a question on
the ballot
we have used ballot initiatives as
a campaign and advocacy tool for decades
lindsay lasalle is a drug policy
strategist and she's worked on a lot of
these state ballot initiatives
the legislature is often afraid to act
but one problem with changing laws this
way with a simple ballot initiative
is that the state still has to figure
out the details
and that isn't always easy for example
in new jersey
no one really knows what's going to
happen to all the people who are
incarcerated or have arrest records
for something that's now legal the other
challenge for these laws is that they
create a gap with the federal government
even though it's legal in several states
at the federal level marijuana is still
classified as one of the most serious
drugs
equal to heroin and lsd and that puts
federal drug laws in direct
conflict with state laws in all sorts of
ways
legal marijuana businesses have a really
hard time getting
any federal-backed bank to take their
money and they can't sell their product
across state lines
so a farm in california can't sell to a
store in nevada
even though it's legal in both states
and because the federal government
considers marijuana a
controlled substance scientists
researching the effects of it
often face problems with funding and
testing
but as more people in more states choose
to legalize marijuana
this gap is going to become
unsustainable having the more
conservative states like
south dakota and montana and arizona
passing means that people have to
consider it at the federal level in a
much more robust way
we've seen something similar happen
before at first same-sex marriage only
became legal in the u.s
state by state but by 2015
70 percent of americans lived in states
that had
legal same-sex marriage that same year
it became legal throughout the country
transformed in this country in the
course of about 25 to 30 years
in terms of cannabis legalization being
an
absolutely toxic infringe issue which is
what it was
um to one now where candidates of both
parties
are embracing it americans attitudes on
the war on drugs
and the mass incarceration it led to are
changing
and more and more of them are ready for
those laws to change
but if politicians won't do it they will
[Music]
do
[Music]
me